So now we're going to see a representation of Boolean formulas
in Python that we're going to be using
to then write a function is satisfied
that checks whether a given Boolean formula
and a given assignment of true false values
to that Boolean formula or rather to the variables
in that Boolean formula satisfies it.
So first, we have a variable numvariables,
which is simply the number of variables that are in the Boolean formula,
the number of distinct variables that is.
The Boolean formula itself is represented
as a list of lists where each inner list is a clause.
For example, this inner list is the clause X1 or X2 or not X3,
and you can see that the variables that are negated are negative.
This clause would be X2 or not X4.
And this clause is not X1 or X3 or X4.
And then of course each individual clause would be anded together.
Assignment is a list of true false assignments to the individual variables.
Note that assignment has one more element in it
than the number of variables.
The first one is actually just a place holder.
It doesn't do anything.
We're only concerned with the second element through the end of the list.
Now if we have these individual assignments to the variables
and then we print is satisfied of these,
we can see that it returns true.
This is a satisfied Boolean formula
or rather this Boolean formula is satisfied by this assignment
where X1 is true, X2 is true, X3 is true, and X4 true.
And if you run C through this and check,
you'll see that that is in fact the case.
Now if we change assignment to true, false, true, true,
then we can see that this assignment does not satisfy
the Boolean formula and returns false.
So your job is to write the is satisfied function
to fill in the body of the function so that it correctly
interprets whether a Boolean formula is satisfied by a given assignment.